e se fosse possível pessoas idosas baixa
renda
a baixa escolaridade às vezes quase
analfabeta e também portadora de
problemas portadores de problemas de
memória às vezes severos utilizarem
computadores internet e se incluírem a
conseguirem participar dessa nossa
moderna sociedade digital e se isso
fosse possível eu sou médico geriatra e
faz uma pior fazem perguntas bem
específicas para a gente na primeira
pergunta que fazem o médico geriatra é
essa
qual foi o avô ou avó que fez vocês e
médico geriatra já já já se pergunta
dessa forma né
e quando fizeram essa pergunta pra mim
como começou essa história essa história
começa porque eu tive dois avô a voz e
um é pra fazenda comigo a gente ele
dirigia o automóvel a gente trabalhava
na fazenda juntos nas férias é
fantástico e outro da mesma idade estava
praticamente em cima de uma cama não se
lembrava de mais nada mal conseguir
falar com a gente e era um contraste
incrível um paradoxo como duas pessoas
da mesma idade um conde está tão bem e
outro podia estar tão mal que aconteceu
na na trajetória dessas pessoas que
pudesse explicar isso
isso talvez eu tivesse 10 e 11 anos de
idade eu já pensava nisso e eu via meu
avô que era doente né na época se falava
esclerosado não tinha ainda esse
conceito de doença já os raios e 1
milhão nem pequeno e assistia televisão
eu fazia assim na frente do rosto dele
né ele não nem desviar o olhar e eu
pensava assim que está acontecendo aí
dentro que está acontecendo dentro dessa
pessoa que a gente não consegue mais se
comunicar com ela
a partir dessa dessa idéia é que depois
não foi até meu inconsciente não eu fui
para da saúde fez medicina sempre muito
interessado e lidar com pessoas idosas e
nessa nessa minha formação não é de
trabalhar com ele
casos aconteceram duas coisas que
estavam aqui estavam concomitantes o
envelhecimento que estava ocorrendo no
brasil não está ocorrendo ainda mas
naquela época era uma coisa mais nova
década de 80 década de 90
isso se juntava um fenômeno na que era
chegada da internet a chegada do uso
comum dos computadores dos computadores
no nosso dia a dia e eu ficava pensando
puxa vida uma ferramenta tão poderosa de
um lado e do outro lado pessoas
envelhecendo se isolando e com essa
epidemia que a gente chama de epidemia
das demências nada desse problema mental
que ocorre onde as pessoas vão perdendo
a memória e perdendo a capacidade
funcional
diante disso e já pensando em como unir
essas duas paixões nas falas de paixões
aqui né pelos idosos por essas
tecnologias
eu comecei a pensar em como unir uma
ferramenta tão poderosa pra gente que
tanto precisava disso
diante disso a gente eu comecei a
desenvolver algumas oficinas onde eu
gostava as pessoas idosas vai trabalhar
e para usar os computadores
isso já começou isso foi no ano 2000
esse trabalho já está fazendo 13 anos
eu gosto muito de tirar as fotos das
mãos adoro as mãos das pessoas na
manuseando a máquina ea gente foi
aperfeiçoando esse trabalho de é colocar
pessoas mais velhas em grupos né e
aprendendo e se desenvolvendo nesse
universo digital ele tinha hoje em dia
de inclusão digital né
essa inclusão digital esse processo foi
sendo aperfeiçoado desde 2002 2003 2006
e a gente foi juntando as pessoas vêm os
equipamentos necessários e o que
aconteceu nesse trajeto
surgiu mais um fenômeno que cada vez
mais nos chama a atenção à questão da
sustentabilidade como como fazer a
inclusão digital desses idosos também
estimular a memória dele reabilitar a
memória deles de um jeito que seja
viável jeito que seja sustentável
esses são os interfaces que a gente
testou que a gente trabalhou com essas
pessoas e essas oficinas que a gente
chama de oficina da lembrança nelas se
elas foram se desenvolvendo e foram
chegando no modelo atual
esse modelo atual ele procura unir todos
esses conceitos a ele
a gente procura trabalhar com pessoas
com problemas de memória em vários graus
essas pessoas elas são reunidas ea gente
convida alunos da medicina da
universidade do sul de santa catarina da
unisul a participar desse projeto
o que acontece muito interessante esse é
o lantena medicina ele põe o pé na
universidade e já começa a entender o
que o idoso e vai funcionar já no ensino
este idoso a usar computadores e é uma
troca muito forte todo mundo da idade
dessas pessoas com os computadores eles
têm facilidade em ensinar eles agora
começa a aprender de odontologia de
começa a aprender quem é esse idoso quem
é essa pessoa aí vão evoluindo junto com
essas pessoas depois de manter as aulas
de geriatria eles vão aprender geriatria
e no final da universidade eles vão
cuidar desses idosos que eles ensinaram
1 informática
eles fecham um ciclo de aprendizado dos
dois
os dois vão se cuidando e vão evoluindo
juntos né
esse projeto também tem a ver com com
várias gerações como mistura de pessoas
de classes sociais de cores de nações na
e de várias cidades porque o ser humano
é assim o ser humano que convive nas
suas várias né e vive nas suas várias
diferenças quando o método e as oficinas
a gente tem 20 encontros mais ou menos
de uma hora e meia cada um onde é a
essas pessoas de uma família ter o
gênero chegando a 11 entender um pouco
de computador outro entende que a gente
sempre começa pela psicomotricidade
sempre usando o paradigma na ou o padrão
do pc
a idéia dessa metáfora do computador
pessoal onde ele aprende a usar o mouse
envolve habilidade nas ruas precisa e
habilidade a no segundo momento ele vai
fazer vários tipos de jogos então o que
acontece aqui ele e quebra o mito ele
quer o medo do computador então ele ele
é uma fase lútea uma fase divertida de
uso de jogos depois dos jogos
o livro ele como adulto ele começa a
perguntar mas pra que eu quero esse
computador na o que eu quero fazer com
isso
esse objeto com essa ferramenta ea gente
apresenta os browsers por exemplo ea
robyn o google ele começa a ganhar e
começa a tomar posse desse tipo de
equipamento e para finalizar a nossa
oficina ele vai curar o correio
eletrônico e que isso é uma ferramenta
cooperativa onde toma noção do próximo
onde começa a trabalhar em equipe com as
outras pessoas os alunos vão ajudando e
todo esse processo em paralelo ocorre a
nossa avaliação da saúde essas pessoas o
quanto e como nós estamos conseguindo
também promover a memória ea capacidade
cognitiva dessas pessoas nesse processo
de aprendizado
isso dura cerca de uma oficina desta
dura de cerca de 2 a 3 meses em cerca de
30 horas na ao todo pra cada grupo de
idosos e depois eles têm o acesso à
máquina o acesso aos laboratórios para
dar continuidade
é assim com zoom digital e quais são os
resultados até hoje a gente tem a
companhia cerca de 450 pessoas 200
pessoas que já sofreram intervenção há
mais de sete anos ea gente tem memória
da memória melhora da memória redução do
declínio cognitivo dessas pessoas
redução de episódios depressivos e
também esse processo é usado para
rastrear se a pessoa tem algum problema
cognitivo que a impeça de usar as
máquinas e qual é e qual é o próximo
passo é que acabou acontecendo é que a
gente possa transformar isso em uma
ferramenta de saúde
pública que isso possa ser ampliado com
a sociedade
e pra isso né ah eu consegui convencer
dá uma grande tecnologia está a
trabalhar esses dados e ampliar a
capacidade desses trabalhos ela vai
mostrar um pouquinho da continuidade dos
resultados
então como o andré falou esse é o
trabalho em equipe é onde a gente tem
uma junção aqui da teoria do método e o
método que a gente tem desenvolvido pra
estudar mais amplamente né e
populacionalmente nos efeitos do uso da
internet sobre a saúde das pessoas
idosas são os estudos populacionais como
por exemplo o estudo até floripa que é
desenvolvido aqui na em florianópolis
com redor das pessoas acima de 60 anos
de idade conduzida pela universidade em
tom e estudantes
e como está a situação de uso de
internet comparando o prazer
florianópolis e inglaterra
na praia as pessoas idosas estão no
brasil a gente ainda tem muito pra
caminhada apesar de ter dobrado nem
passou de cinco para dez por cento
percentual de idosos que usam a internet
no brasil na inglaterra esse percentual
já está acima de 50% em florianópolis
estaria numa situação intermediária
muito bem em florianópolis é a capital
onde as pessoas acima de 60 anos mais
usam internet existe em muitas
desigualdades no acesso e uso da
internet a gente vê por exemplo que as
pessoas mais jovens também estão
incluídas digitalmente do que os mais
velhos apesar do uso da internet têm
aumentado mais entre os mais velhos
as pessoas que estudaram chegaram até a
faculdade o nível superior também usam
mais a internet do que as pessoas que
não estudaram é os homens usam mais a
internet do que as mulheres e as pessoas
das camadas sociais mais favorecidas
também estão mais incluídas digitalmente
do que a população menos favorecida
e qual é a influência disso sobre a
capacidade cognitiva sobre a memória
gente vê aqui que a classe social é um
dos fatores mais importantes que
determina a manutenção da memória vocês
podem ver que a barra do lado esquerdo
embaixo que corresponde ao grupo mais
pobre teve um declínio cognitivo muito
mais acentuado do que o grupo mais rico
que está na faixa a linha azul do lado
direito quando a gente incluir mais uma
variável nessa equação que o uso de
internet
vocês podem ver ele o resultado o grupo
mais rico em vermelho grupo mais pobre
né com uma variação de memória negativo
seja perdeu memória ao longo do tempo
que acontece quando a gente olha esses
dois grupos separando quem passou na
internet a quem lá não um caso na
internet
o grupo que começou na internet tendo
isabel melhor do que o grupo que não
usou ou seja não consiga manter a sua
memória por mais tempo
o grupo rico agora olha o que acontece
com o grupo mais pobre grupo mais pobre
que passou na internet é aquela faixa
vermelha que está lá alto quer
ultrapassar o desempenho do grupo mais
rico a e fica até com uma situação
melhor do que o grupo mais rico que
nunca usou a internet ou seja o acesso
eo uso da internet e de menor
ae as desigualdades sociais entre as
pessoas também não faz com que as
pessoas recuperem mais a funcionalidade
depois delas terem perdido mantenham por
mais tempo as suas funções à sua
independência sua autonomia participar
mais de programas preventivos como
rastreamento para câncer de mama
também para câncer de intestino com mais
frutas e vegetais por dia fazem mais
atividade física e tem uma qualidade de
vida melhor
além de ter uma sobrevida melhor em dez
anos
ou seja é tudo de bom então a internet
melhor a cognição a funcionalidade
participação nos exames preventivos tem
um estilo de vida mais saudável uma
qualidade de vida melhor uma sobrevida
melhor ea inclusão digital também é o do
gradiente social sem falar na questão do
do empoderamento que essa pessoa recebe
é porque muitas vezes é uma pessoa que
está em casa que já não tem não está
mais trabalhando está aposentada e só
fica assistindo televisão quando você
essa pessoa se torna digitalmente
incluída
ela passa a poder se comunicar e trocar
interagir com todo mundo né ele passa
por exemplo conseguir se comunicar com
neto pelo facebook por outras do por
outras formas
então a gente tem grandes perspectivas
de desenvolvimento desse trabalho
incluindo a aplicação das oficinas na
ufsc e nem a continuar expandindo o
floripa que têm queixas de memória o
desenvolvimento de uma intervenção
social para promover a independência na
demência e à continuação das oficinas
nessa equipe que faz oficinas muito
obrigado